[Music]
[Applause]
oink's we should go over there Oh
jinkies we should wander this away Oh
Mamma Mia here I go again here is your
veggies and salad to eat here's the
crack cocaine you're doing good you're
doing good you have any idea how fast
you were going I'll give you a hint it's
somewhere between stops and really fast
I need to get this barrel ready our
daughter she's turning 3 we're gonna put
her in and send her down on her way
doctor I know they're large breast
implants this is a pretty good first
date we should get out of here it's
gonna kill us I think he's got a hamster
look I think he's gotta dildo
hey guys hope you enjoyed that that's a
little preview the show that we have in
store for you on the tour all that
footage actually is from our June shows
when we went on that for city run and I
know a lot of you guys were like to have
four cities that's not a tour that's
like a vacation between states and we
know and the reason that we did such a
small set of that was because we wanted
to make sure that this show was actually
good because we we do a lot more than
just a meet-and-greet or just Let's
Plays and when we all got together and
we thought about this project we wanted
it to be a show that even if you weren't
a fan of my channel or a fan of any of
our videos you could still enjoy the
show objectively because it combines
like music improv dancing audience
participation we we wanted to reinforce
this idea that the show is different
every time you see it and it may not be
drastically different but with improv
and the choices that you guys make
during the show it can go a long way so
if you want to see where the show is
gonna be check out markiplier com or
check out the link in the description
goes the same place
markiplier comm you'll see all of the
different cities that we're going to
we're going to hit East Coast we're
gonna hit West Coast a lot of the
Midwest we're gonna do a lot of that but
also we're gonna go to Europe Marais we
don't have a ton of venues in Europe we
got about seven or eight but it still
should be a ton of fun and it'll be so
exciting especially for us that we
travel for conventions but we've never
traveled out for a tour like this where
everything rides on our performance but
I couldn't be happier with where the
show is and I couldn't be more grateful
that you guys are joining us on this
little adventure that we got going on so
check out the dates and check out the
link down there the tickets will go on
sale 9 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
tomorrow which is September 7th and 9:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time is the people
in the comments should be able to help
you figure out what your time zone means
for 9:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time but
I also wanted to mention there's a VIP
component to this the venues like
require you to have a certain number of
seats are that our VIP or something and
I wanted to do something special for for
people that did want to get something
like that I wanted an experience so for
this particular run
all of these shows before the main show
starts not only will the VIP get in
early but I will be doing an acoustical
cover set I will be playing my guitar
and I will be singing songs and I
promise they're not all gonna be at
cheerin well I mean there's there might
be some edgier and I can't stop myself I
love the boy too much but yeah it's the
first time that I'll be performing
musically in that capacity since
marching band in high school
and I wasn't even singing that a man if
I could play the trumpet and sing at the
same time that'd be amazing but yeah
ii-i've been practicing a lot and I'm to
the point where I'm really happy with my
music and my singing ability which which
was never like like III didn't even know
if I was going to do that but I feel
pretty good about it and it's gonna be a
smaller setting so it should be a nice
little intimate moment where I can
perform for you guys in a way that I've
never performed before and I think
that's really cool so those tickets go
on sale tomorrow as well all of it is
available through the link in the
description below or go straight -
markiplier comm and find out all the
info that you need once again tickets go
on sale September 7th 9 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time check it out then and
check it out there and thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
were at one of our shows let people know
down in the comments what you think of
it and thanks again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye